Jiji gorgeous says she was detained in  Dubai hi guys it's GG welcome back to my  channel the 24 year old YouTube star  took to Instagram Tuesday to share the  scary news posting this pic of her  giving her girlfriend that Getty a huge  hug after reportedly being released  writing in the caption after being  detained and held at the Dubai Airport  for over five hours this was the moment  my baby came to rescue me yesterday was  one of the scariest moments of my entire  life and I wouldn't wish it upon anyone  how you can be denied entry somewhere  just because of who you are is seriously  disgusting and also very scary this  further proves the need for change TMZ  reports GG born Gregory Lazar ato was  detained at immigration in the Dubai  Airport when an officer told her quote I  was told you are transgender  you cannot come into the country Jiji  became famous for documenting her  transition on social media I want to be  female